si on le terrain une centaine de
migrants ont été arrêtés dans la nuit
par les autorités polonaises à les
biélorusses organisent le retour des
migrants un centre logistique a été
réquisitionné à quelques mètres de la
frontière et gorges à notre envoyé
spécial pour rt international a pu se
rendre sur place
à la suite de l'échec de la tentative
d'aujourd'hui de prendre d'assaut la
frontière polonaise de la prendre par la
force des dizaines de migrants ont
exprimé la volonté d'abandonner tout
cela d'abandonner tout c'est quand la
vie sauvage et de se rendre dans un
centre spécial qui a été mise en place
par les autorités biélorusses pour eux
c'est un centre de commerce et
logistique situé à 500 mètres de la
frontière
la décision a été prise rapidement pour
que les gens n'aient pas à passer une
seconde nuit sur le goudron
vous voyez qui si une partie de l'espace
peut être libérée des marchandises en
deux heures elles ont été transférées
dans la partie la plus éloignée de
l'entreprise libérant ainsi environ 40 %
de l'espace
de plus des équipes de médecins
arriveront et effectueront une prise de
température afin de regrouper ceux qui
ont la fièvre le cas échéant dans l'un
des couloirs à louer
ce que vous voyez tout autour de moi est
un centre logistique près de la
frontière dans la vie normale avant que
les points de contrôle à la frontière
nette était fermée en raison de la crise
migratoire il était utilisé pour le tri
de fret de marchandises tout ce genre de
choses
maintenant le gouvernement biélorusse
l'a organisé il ya des tapis de sol ici
qui ont été fournis par la partie
biélorusse les migrants ont désormais un
toit sur la tête il n'y a pas de vent il
fait beaucoup plus chaud ici à
l'intérieur
en fait pour la première fois ici je
peux voir ce que les gens portent sous
le revêtement extérieur parce
qu'auparavant ils mettaient tous les
jours autant de vêtements que possible
sur eux donc cela ne peut pas être
comparée aux conditions dans lesquelles
ils devaient survie brière encore
voici un nouveau groupe de migrants
comme vous pouvez le constater qu'ils
arrivent au centre
donc fondamentalement le but principal
de ce local est de fournir à l'abri
appropriée aux plus vulnérables afin que
les polonais ne leur dirige pas le feu
des projecteurs dans le visage pendant
qu'ils essaient de dormir il n'y a pas
de vent et s'il pleut c'est jean son
protégé ici et alors que va-t-il se
passer ensuite les autorités biélorusses
vont continuer à essayer d'établir
l'identité de chacun d'entre eux car
certains n'ont même pas de papiers sur
eux
et puis ils seront ramenés espérons le
ils rentreront chez eux là d'où ils
viennent quels que soient ces endroits
parce que c'est leur objectif principal
ils sont venus dire nous voulons rentrer
chez nous nous ne voulons plus aller en
europe nous avons abandonné cette idée
nous voulons rentrer à la maison les
autorités vont essayer d'identifier ces
personnes en espérant que cela
facilitera leur retour